I think the number one thing that
strikes you when you try to build
technology in India is the resource
constraints you know if you want to
build technology that actually fits the
lowest common denominator that actually
works everywhere the resource
constraints that you think about cost
bandwidth the diversity of users I think
those are extreme in India because of
that if you build systems that somehow
work in those constraints you are
innovating for the world you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen heusinger dr. Shriram
Rajamani is the distinguished scientist
and the managing director of the
Microsoft research lab in Bangalore he's
dedicated his career to advancing
globally applicable science in the
testbed that is India he is by any
measure a world-class researcher and
leader he's also as you'll find out
shortly a world-class storyteller today
dr. Rajamani talks about the unique
challenges and opportunities of leading
MSRs research efforts in India and what
it takes to build a robust research
ecosystem in a country of huge
disparities he also dispels some
preconceptions about poor and
marginalized populations and explains
why frugal innovation may be one key to
solving societal scale problems that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
Shriram Rajamani welcome to the podcast
thank you excited to be here you're a
distinguished scientist and the managing
director of Microsoft Research India and
that's a big job that encompasses a lot
not only your own research but the
research of the people that you
supervise and guide and direct so tell
us in broad strokes what you do for a
living what does a day in your life look
like what get you up in the morning oh
boy
so home I'm a morning person so I'm up
quite early I usually read in the
morning I have a big reading list my you
know colleagues they send me a lot of
reading material about work that they do
and I usually have a week or two worth
of reading material in advance that's my
reading queue so my mornings is usually
spent reading at home and then most of
the days actually spend in small group
discussions where we sort of take a
research topic get into it with real
depth and we ask many difficult
questions are we doing the right thing
are we investing this right should we
change direction should we pivot that's
the most fun part of my job I'm usually
home by 5:00 and with my family it will
group yoga class in the evening Nestle I
might break in the evening and then late
evening there's Redman calls so starting
like 8:00 p.m. 9:00 p.m. for a couple of
hours there's usually conversations with
either researchers in Redmond our party
groups in Redmond I do spend a lot time
traveling because as Mike services we
engage with academia not only in India
but throughout the world and I come here
three four times a year so that's
hopefully gives you a sense for what I
do yeah so tell me about your personal
passion and what drives you what
questions are you asking that you would
really like to answer what problems
would you really like to solve tell me
what your heart is for research yeah so
my personal research is in systems my
PhD was in formal verification a lot of
my personal research quest is actually
understanding these extremely
complicated computing systems that have
really transformed everything around us
understanding what it takes to build
them so that they are stable they are
robust and they do what we intend them
to do so that's my personal passion but
these days actually a lot of my time is
spent not only on my own work but the
work of my colleagues which ranges from
you know mathematics algorithms to
artificial intelligence to machine
learning the systems to human-computer
interaction a lot of my energy gets
spent on understanding these various
topics I'm a research junkie so I
actually I spend a lot of time learning
that's what I do that's that's my main
passion is learning Microsoft Research
has labs around the world and each one
brings something unique to the research
endeavor so give our listeners a brief
history of MSR India it's kind of
fascinating what's your particular
guiding mission and what were the
particulars and opportunities for
opening a lab in Bangalore the
opportunities in a place like India are
many first of all it's a country with
more than a billion people a lot of them
very young right so there's tremendous
motive potential for talent and what we
can do there it's a growing economy and
to just give you a sense right when I
graduated in 91 most of my class left
the u.s. to study but now if you look at
the people that are graduating a lot of
them are staying back because there's
enough economic opportunities there's a
lot of interesting things actually
happening in India it is a very
interesting testbed to give you a sense
right there is about 150 spoken
languages each with in a hundred
thousand two million or more people
speaking those languages which you can
see how different that is from a place
like the US and if you look at actually
languages that are spoken by fewer
people still tens of thousands there
would be a thousand five hundred huge
disparities in socio-economic conditions
you know you will find extremely rich
people extremely poor people everything
in between and why infrastructure
variance and if you go to a city you'll
be just like in the US and if you go to
a village there'll be like nothing so in
terms of actually why we went there we
went there because of talent and the
opportunities in terms of how we
converged on what we work on there and
what's the sort of the unique value that
MSR India brings we've always tried to
strike a balance between globally
applicable science and being inspired by
India as a testbed so you know as a
parent right India has always had a
really good mathematics talent that's
one of the reasons why we work in
algorithms we have a very strong set of
people that work in algorithms there
over time we have built expertise in
systems and machine learning and we also
work on socio-economic development which
is a very local thing in India and we
didn't plant these areas ahead of time
we sort of meander around and we have
converged on these areas for 15 years we
have sort of evolved over time and
actually MSR let's lab directors the
flexibility we just evolved in that
story to say which is wonderful as both
a scientist yourself and a leader in
technology you're in a unique position
to reflect on trends and I would say
both those that you observe and those
you create so what does it take in your
mind
Shriram to be a leader in technology
today and how are you executing towards
that in an age of AI most of a
scientists job is to predict how the
world is going to look like in five
years from now ten years from now and
nobody has a perfect crystal ball right
so a lot of it is actually based on your
intuition the intuition of your
colleagues social conversations you have
with people and painting a picture of
the how the world is going to be five
years from now ten years from now let me
give some examples I sort of illustrate
what I mean
so I was a grad student at Berkeley in
the late 90s and know during that time
if you sort of think about security we
always thought about security of data
much like physical security like you
store your valuables in a locker and you
lock them up and then you do access
control you sort of you know decide who
gets access to your house and similarly
you decide you know who gets access to
your data so most of security was about
access control we have a very you know
fine young researcher in our lab is name
is psychic Gohan around thousand eight
he started thinking oh no that's not the
right way to think about security in the
Internet age we don't actually think
about not only who has access to data
but what they do with it which is a real
conceptual shift in how they think about
security and when he started thinking
about in 2008 there were very few people
that subscribe to that view right you
know he was like a lone ranger working
on that for several years
and he built tools to actually qualify
those ideas and many years later when
gdpr came he was already ready Wow with
frameworks and so on and he built a
framework called beta map for the past
decade that was so influential in how
Microsoft thinks about gdpr compliance
another example I would give you is and
I know you've had Monica korma podcast
so he worked on you know a machine
learning system called extreme
classification you know
so Amy refresh your listeners as to what
that is about you know today machine
learning people think about classifying
objects or you know data into small
number of classes you know you could
take a picture and classify it as a cat
or a dog but Monica thinks about how to
classify things so that the number of
categories could be in the order of
millions right right and when you first
started doing that people thought he was
crazy but today there are many many
applications and advertisements in
recommendations in ranking and extreme
classification is now a unique sub area
in machine learning that she started
today if you go to nips Ric ml there is
actually workshop and extreme
classification right right that's an
example of again foresight into how the
world will look in a several years down
the line a lot of what you need to paint
a picture of the future is to have a
hypothesis have self confidence in it
and have a community that works with you
to create that future LSR India focuses
on four key areas of technology research
and you've alluded to them already but
let's talk about them specifically
algorithms systems ml and AI and
technology for emerging markets or Tim
talked briefly about how your lab is
contributing in each of these areas we
don't have to get granular but give us
an overview of the vision for each of
these areas and why they kind of go
together overlap and have their own
space as well algorithms is pretty much
the foundations of computing right
that's the math behind
I know data science the math behind
cryptography the math behind everything
that we do in computing and we are very
fortunate to have amazing incredible
minds that actually work in this space a
lot of machine learning actually starts
out as algorithms
now thinking that actually happens today
will lead to machine learning algorithms
maybe five years down the line ten years
down the line and today if you look at
them they'll be math equations written
on a whiteboard so our algorithms group
does a lot of leading-edge work that is
going to only see the light of the day
five years down the line ten years down
the line but that said things that they
did ten years ago are now seeing the
light of the day
for example we worked on you know things
like topic modeling which are now
incorporated into working tools that are
used by many many people inside the
company trade that's an example one
other thing that people work on is you
know you may have heard a lot about deep
learning and one of the things that is
interesting about deep learning is that
even though it works in many cases we
don't quite even understand why it works
what the limitations of that are when it
will fail and so you know people in the
algorithms group try and dissect and
understand why deep learning that's what
it does what its limitations are and
understanding what algorithmic tweaks
that we need to do to make it even
better right and then moving on you know
to machine learning artificial
intelligence that's a very wide spectrum
I already spoke a little bit about
extreme classification which talks about
classifiers in the large yeah you know
we also work on machine learning in the
small we work on you know edge ml which
is actually machine learning running on
very very small devices devices that you
could buy for $2 to $5 and you know how
do you make machine learning algorithms
work on them you know another very
interesting topic that we work on is
something called approximate nearest
neighbor let me say what there is today
the way search engines work is by using
something called information retrieval
but that's esterday going forward what
happens is that because of deep neural
networks the search is actually done in
the higher dimensional space and this
requires entirely new algorithmic
thinking and you know people in our lab
they span over all the way from the
algorithms to machine learning so
there's new algorithms that we have been
designing on how to do this nearest
neighbor search which have the potential
to transform the way search engines are
built and then moving on to systems you
know systems is the foundation and the
infrastructure on which everything else
is built including AI and ml so we work
on the interaction between machine
learning in systems we sort of think
about how machine learning can make
systems better how can we get the
signals that actually come from our data
centers where the data centers are
constantly running you know billions and
billions of computation and something
fails we get those signals back crashes
we get those signals back how can we use
machine learning to map those things
back to actual code that people write so
that when something fails we can point
out the hey this fails because this line
of code is actually not working right we
try to use machine learning to figure
out how to optimize cogs which is cost
of goods right we also try and build
systems for better machine learning how
do you build better infrastructure so
that we can utilize GPUs better and do
better GPU training and in the final
area which is technologies emerging
markets you know we do things ranging
from public health to education do we
study illiteracy we study Human Rights
how to build technology so that they are
just and fair so those are the kinds of
things that we do
let's talk for a minute about why India
is the ideal place for disruptive
technology and how constraints drive
innovation how are the realities of life
in developing areas of the country
turning some current assumptions about
technology upside down as I mentioned
right India has wide
you know socio-economic disparity in
Bangalore you could go to a mall that
would look much like Blue Square and on
the other end you could go to rural area
in which you know they might not even be
electric power I think the number one
thing that strikes you when you try to
build technology in India is the
resource constraints you know if you
want to build technology that actually
fits the lowest common denominator that
actually works everywhere the resource
constraints that you had to think about
cost bandwidth the diversity of users I
already mentioned the number of spoken
languages and so on I think those are
extreme in India because of that right
if you build systems that somehow work
in those constraints you are innovating
for the world in a once one one say I've
heard is actually if you make something
work in India it'll work anywhere that's
actually something I've heard you know
and it's so true right if you sort of go
to a rural area and open up your mobile
and let's download on something it just
spins forever right how do you build a
system that supports those users as well
as uses in the city that I think is a
tremendous opportunity so in our lab we
actually have taught a lot about this
one of the terms that actually describe
best what we do is called frugal
innovation innovation that actually
thinks about cost essentially as its
core because if something is not
low-cost it's just not going to fly
right and the thinking about technology
as an amplifier of human ability I think
so technology should not replace people
because you know there's no point in
doing that all right so the point is
actually use technology to amplify human
ability because the real scarcity is
actually found right right and skill so
how can you amplify skill that a few
people have to serve more people
thinking about poor underserved
populations a lot more carefully
you know distinguishing between their
needs and wants most of us actually in
the West think about you know when we
work with poor people we think about
health education right those should be
their needs right but in reality if you
study them they have a lot of wants now
they want entertainment they want
employment right but thinking about who
are not as just consumers of information
but producers of information they have
very many interesting things to say
thinking about the lived experience of
the two billion people that are not yet
part of the digital economy because of
many many reasons illiteracy thinking
about illiteracy as a cognitive deficit
and thinking about you could give them
the best smartphone you could give them
the best 3G 4G connectivity but if they
don't have next you let me see how are
you going to connect them and include
them I think the final thing I would say
is that when you design technologies you
know to serve this kind of community
being completely honest to yourself that
it actually works and doing rigorous
scientific evaluations to actually see
whether it makes the difference or is
this a shiny object that you just
designed in a lab you know just because
it is fun right you know your harkening
back to ed Kouta who was on the show and
i know he did work he used to be years
and some of the stories he told on the
podcast he was on it encourage people to
go listen to that one because there's
actual stories of things that they
thought would work in particular
scenarios that they just wildly didn't
but not for the reasons they thought
they wouldn't right it's like story I
love stories yeah so we have a
researcher her name is Indrani Medicis
she is one of the world's leading
experts on illiteracy so you know she
and a bunch of others wanted to build a
job website for low income people sort
of like a you know monster.com or
something for like cooks or drivers and
you know low income labor and so they
built it with only pictures right
because these people you know wouldn't
be able to read text so they built the
whole interface using pictures and I
remember you know there's a slum near
our lab so they wanted to do a pilot in
this slum so there was a lot of
discussion in the lab about how to put a
computer there so that the computer
won't be stolen and so that it actually
you can access it but you know you can't
walk away with it and you know
everything you know
could apply using pictures you know you
could actually look at the job listings
and they did all of that right
and after that they deployed it and the
usage was zero it was there and people
were curious about it but nobody used it
and what it occurred in Ronnie was that
the reason is actually they have no
conception of what this thing would even
do and so what they did was you know
they enacted something like a soap opera
in the lab with actors from the lab
there's a woman who self is complaining
to her husband that she needs domestic
help and then the husband goes and
registers the fact that they need
domestic work in this site and then
there's a woman who comes accesses his
computer in the slum and she clicks on
this and she gets introduced and they
meet and she gets a job this is now
being run as a screen saver in the
computer and then the usage of this
thing skyrocketed interesting right
so in Ronnie's main conclusion right is
that when illiteracy is not just about
textual literacy it's about lack of
context and how wellness and unless you
actually put yourself in the shoes of a
person who has never seen something like
this before
you're not gonna fix this by you know
just pictures right so that's an example
of things that you'd think that would
work but wouldn't work yeah you and your
colleagues are tackling some what you
call societal scale issues healthcare
education agriculture employment
connectivity transparency we've talked
about quite a few of these already give
us some more context for the research
projects that your teams are working on
that might give us cause for hope for
some societal scale solutions yeah so I
can tell you a few stories I already
told you the literacy story yeah so one
project where we have made a lot of
traction is a project called 99 dots
which is in our own technologies for
tuberculosis medication adherence this
is project that was initiated by Bill
T's and Andrew cross so the context for
this is that TB is a curable disease but
you have to take medication for six
months and if someone falls out of
medication regimen
then they get something called
drug-resistant TB which is both
contagious and fail so the only way to
cure TB is to make sure that a
healthcare worker meets with the patient
every day for six months to ensure that
they have taken medication and you can
imagine how cumbersome it is for both
the healthcare worker and the patient
right
so suppose we could use technology to
get that information then the healthcare
worker could spend all their time on
people that are actually not taking
medication so they designed a sensing
system which they iterated many many
times but what finally works is actually
they work with bill manufacturers and
they designed a new paper strips so
they're actually when they dispense the
pill it reveals a phone number in which
the patient is actually counseled to
give a free call and the other side a
computer picks up the call and it
records that oh this person is now
taking a drug so the computer knows when
the calls are coming and when the calls
don't come there's like a red bar saying
this person hasn't called and then the
counsellor spends time on that patient
now this was started out as a research
project in our lab and then we spun it
off into a non-profit because you know
the government wanted to adopt it and
you know the Gates Foundation USA they
wanted to fund it so we spun it off into
a separate startup company called ever
well and it's just walking distance from
our office they employ about 20 people
and they've enrolled more than 200,000
patients some other examples are one of
the things we work on these days is road
safety so traffic accidents are a huge
killer of people in India and so we have
a research project called hams where
what you're doing is just using a
smartphone we can monitor both the
behavior of the driver and the
surroundings so we can actually know
whether a driver is sleepy you know
whether they are wearing a seatbelt you
know whether they are talking on the
phone when they are driving you could
imagine how this technology could be
used to monitor fleets how to make
driving safe and a very interesting
application of this is an automated
driver licensing so today if you go to
Dehradun as of two months you should go
to a driving test
there is no instructor it's a found it's
a phone and then you drive and then an
automatic printout gets printed at
saying actually these are the things you
did right these are the things you
didn't do right and you passed a failed
Oh
interesting so let me add a few more
right you know I imagine hams you know
like you know blend net is another
project you know because connectivity
infrastructure is such a big issue if
you go to you know rural areas right you
can get text messages by but if you try
and download a video even you will see
the wheel spinning forever and you will
be never able to download something so
blender is a very interesting idea where
most of the popular videos and other
bulk things you want to download
actually other people want them to odds
are that somebody else will have it so
blend net is what is called a cloud
connected content distribution network
where if you want to download a
Bollywood movie what you do is actually
you use the 2g 3G only to actually say
what you want and the cloud has some
metadata which actually stores who has
what video the actual video might come
from you right I just connect to the
cloud and say I want this movie but the
actual movie comes by your phone
turning on your Bluetooth or your local
Wi-Fi my phone turning on understanding
it here and peer-to-peer right and using
that so fascinating you know just going
back to your Bollywood movie download
those are for our productions this every
single human emotion and dancing your
money's worth well several trends in
technology have actually broadened the
scope of the problems that we could
solve today you know hyper compute power
sophisticated algorithms and massive
amounts of data but people in the field
are starting to recognize that we need
more than computer scientists to solve
these problems so give us your take on
the trend towards interdisciplinary
research especially in the light of
technology for emerging markets yeah I
think this is a very important question
maybe I'll again actually in the spirit
of storytelling let me actually give
that as an example with the particular
project right you know I mentioned a few
times edge ml right edge ml is about
running machine learning on very small
devices this is actually the dream that
you know today there are these very
small devices and they're primarily used
as sensors and their capability is to
just transmit information to the cloud
and the assumption that they will work
only when there is cloud connectivity
but the html's projects hypothesis is
that what if you could actually do
mission
there but now it's a very difficult
question first of all you have to start
with a math to figure out can you
actually do it that's whatever the
algorithms people come in and then after
the algorithms people figure out that
actually you could do it then you need
the machine learning people to actually
design those algorithms we need systems
people and compilers people to compile
those algorithms to run on those small
devices and then you actually you need
head CI people to think about what this
might really solve now when you imagine
the future right you have to think about
what the algorithms are what the systems
are going to look like and actually how
people are gonna interact with it
alright let's talk about talent or you
alluded to that at the beginning Europe
what we call in the United States of for
a high school you've got a lot of kids
your football team so with billions one
of your problems might not just be that
you have a lot of people to choose from
but you have a competitive environment
for getting the best talent to come to
work with you so what's MSR India's
value proposition to get the best and
brightest AI talent these days so yeah
is a pretty interesting place from a
talent perspective you know we have a
really strong undergraduate population
but our graduate program you know still
lacks critical mass with the number of
PhDs that come out of India so one of
the things we do is that our PhD
recruiting is very global and that's our
hiring opportunity right so we recruit
globally you know from people perhaps of
Indian origin and there are people like
Bill T's and handle cross who are you
know not of Indian origin but they want
to come live there because of India as a
test bit so you know I think one of the
things we have done very cleverly if I
may say so is to think about recruiting
very very globally particularly at the
PhD level and you know even if a small
fraction of Indians living worldwide
want to come back right a small fraction
of a billions to the very large number
or I should say every year right even if
10 people want to return you just you
know pick the best of those 10 and hire
them and then actually with undergrads
we actually work with undergrads in
India we have a program called Research
Fellow program where it's sort of a pre
doctoral program where we take
undergrads and they spend one to two
years with us as research apprentices
and then they go off to do grad school
in the West you know typically in Europe
or in the US and you know in the 15
years we've been running this program I
think we would have graduated maybe 500
such research fellows many of them have
now finished PhDs and they've come back
so you know we spend a lot of time
nurturing young talent you know because
we play the long game that's the way we
work with undergrads and it comes a
value proposition right there are people
like me who want to do honest-to-god
good science right and they want to live
in India here's an environment where you
could do research like anybody else in
the world if you choose to live in India
and then actually you combine that with
locally relevant work like technologies
are emerging markets very connect with
the community think about India as a
testbed and you put those put together
and then you get a different kind of
energy and that's what MSR India is
collaboration seems to be a big trend in
an era of AI and ml research so first I
want you to tell us why collaboration is
really important in your world
particularly and then tell us about some
of the collaborations you're involved in
and how they're bearing fruit yeah so I
already mentioned about
interdisciplinary collaboration in the
lab and I think that's very central to
what we do
but in India the other thing that's very
important for our lab is collaboration
with our ecosystem which is the academic
ecosystem it's quite important because
the graduate program is still not quite
strong so many of our staff are adjunct
faculty in Indian universities so many
of us you know co teach courses we co
supervise PhD students and that's very
integral part of what we do and I think
that has actually built real trust and
credibility with the academic ecosystem
now you mentioned money karma money
karma recently was awarded the SSB price
it's one of the most prestigious awards
in interdisciplinary science also right
there's an Indian National Academy of
Engineering so we have three fellows
from IAE in our lab I'm on or them right
I know we have a MacArthur prize winner
we have a clue to prize winner and so on
so all of these right are not just
bragging about our staff I think these
are really awards to collaborations that
these people had with
community and these recognitions come
not because these guys sit in a lab and
work but they share the work and bring
the energy of the academic community so
that's actually super important in a
place like India talk a little bit about
the research ecosystem there and some of
the work that you're doing to build
community and train people you've
alluded to the research Fellows program
but there are other things you're doing
sort of broader spectrum talk a little
bit about that so one of the things that
we're doing is to for example bring
conferences into India travel grants for
Indian academics are very very hard to
get mm-hmm right you know we are
actually privileged to be in a place
like a Mossad where we could travel and
go to conferences right but many
students in India they just don't have
the ability to go to conferences so if
they can't go to a conference he's try
and bring the conference to India so we
participate in a lot of those kinds of
activities we also organize workshops
years ago I started a series called my
suit Park series where you know we get
high quality peer interaction you know
people get to a community in a small
group and discuss topics for like four
days five days because you know you have
to actually get people to talk to each
other and we spend a lot of time and
energy creating those kinds of
conversations nurturing those kinds of
conversations and under communities very
welcoming of us doing that that's one of
the reasons why people join our lab then
they join our lab they are not in a
bubble they are actually connected to
our environment and connected to the
ecosystem around us
we've talked about what gets you up in
the morning Shriram but this is the part
of the podcast where I ask what could
possibly go wrong
so given the power of AI and its
potential for both great good and great
harm
so anything that keeps you up at night
and if so what are you doing to mitigate
it there's some people who believe that
AI will become like the swash and a
great terminator and come back and kill
all of us
I for one don't believe that I don't
believe that I don't fear very far away
from that but what worries me more is
not the fact that I know every day I
will be you know how powerful and
conquerors but you know I max off to
reliability person you know I am a
systems person I actually want systems
to work well my worry is more that in
our enthusiasm as technologists we
overestimate what hey I can do and
deploy it before it is ready I think
that worries me more than you know a I
can't query us yeah is of course and
trained by data and if the data is not
represented it's going to cost huge
amounts of bias and it's going to take
decisions that systematically amplify in
a human biases that people have people
are aware of this and you know that
keeps me up at night because we all
really think about whether the AI is
actually really helping people not only
in terms of research that I also think
about it in terms of investment now that
having a lab director position to give
you a sense right one of the biggest
promises of AI is natural language
processing because you can now talk to a
computer and if you're an alert read
write that is going to open doors now if
you can't read and write but if you can
speak and the computer can understand
you it's going to bring you into the
part of the digital economy but look at
the investments in NLP they are all in
English in German you know those are the
markets where the money is right and
that's where I feel people are investing
more and more to make you know your
speech assistance
understand you know these cans flying
but what about 150 languages what about
the 1500 languages what about the tribal
language is there
spoken by 10,000 people and all of them
are illiterate right so are we doing
enough investment to include them in
this AI driven economy and so that
disparity I think is something that I
worry about I think it's extremely
important to think about
entrepreneurship right because you know
marginalize people poor people they want
to live better and there are a lot of
energy in them right I think creating
entrepreneurship opportunities for them
so that they can generate economic value
so that you don't just donate money to
them but you sort of enabled them to be
successful and creating businesses and
then creating economic value which will
then lead to an ROI right but the real
difficulty in these kinds of things
right even if you do them they are all
going to be in the knee of the hockey
stick it's going to be many years of
investment before you see the
exponential that is coming up right so I
think the biggest challenge is actually
in persevering through this exponential
it's a very difficult thing to do it's
story time and I would love to hear
yours so even though we've been telling
stories pretty well the whole podcast
let's get a personal story in here tell
us a little bit about your history and
where you've studied where you've worked
what got you started along your path and
how you ended up at MSR in your
leadership position today so I did my
undergrad in India and like you know
most of my colleagues I came here for
graduate school I first did my masters
at UVA at University of Virginia and I
thought that you know maybe I won't be
researcher so I went and became a
programmer I wrote softer in the Silicon
Valley for a few years and I wrote you
know hundreds of thousands of lines of
code and then after a few years I
decided I really want to do research so
I went back to the ph.d program at UC
Berkeley and I did my PhD in formal
verification and after I did my PhD I
used to work on formal verification for
Hardware circuits and you know around
the time I graduated you know I met you
know Jim lares and Amitabh Shrivastava
you know Amitabh was running this place
called programmer productivity Research
Center and they recruited me to see
whether these kinds of formal methods
for hardware can it be used for software
I found it very intriguing so I came
here you know with that in a hook in
mind
and I met Tom wall who is still a
researcher here and he and I did you
know many years of collaboration where
we sort of tried to combine formal
methods both on the hardware area
together with tear improving together
with compiler style stuff that the
software people do to really think about
how to formally validate software mostly
analysis work is what I did when I was
here and then I went back to India
around 2005 in a few months after our
lab started my initial work was on
design software design so there actually
an instead of finding bugs in a driver
after the driver is written think about
how might you write it so that by
construction your software is actually
better so we designed a language called
P where you design software in a
high-level language and you analyze your
design and make sure your design is
robust and then you generate code from
it and that's what runs and you know
methodology from this is actually what
is now being used to run your USB stack
right then I worked on security in MSR
Cambridge to build cloud where you can
actually guarantee that hackers can't
have access to your data so in my own
story I went to MSR India when I was in
my mid-30s and three years ago I became
a lab director so I've had the fortune
of being an individual contributor
researcher a group manager and now a lab
director so that's been my journey
what's one thing that people might not
know about you that may have influenced
you to be a researcher or a leader in
tech I think probably most people don't
know that I'm a village boy my dad used
to be in the agricultural department in
southern India you work for the
government
so I was born and I grew up in villages
with no electric power I'm not that old
right but it's true I'm looking at him
he's not that old but I grew up in
villages in which there was no electric
power
there was no cooking gas so my mom used
to cook with charcoal and firewood yeah
so I have that kind of upbringing
and I think that influences me in many
many ways
I'm the first
person from my family they ever leave my
country and it's sort of full circle for
me to be from that environment go study
here and go back and you know be a
considerable part of our lab work on
technologies that benefit you know rural
people you know people living in poor
areas and so on as we close I want to
give you the last word Shriram you've
compared research to a marathon tell our
listeners who may be just getting into
the race what they have to look forward
to and why in the long run they
shouldn't be afraid of the long run if
you want to do in a science that changes
the world you need to give time it's
extremely important to do that because
to make any research mark it's going to
take many many years because it's you
have to try many things will fail you
know some things will work and even if
some things work it has to actually
gather critical mass it has to attract
attention from people and the right
environment should be there for it to
get deployed and so on so things take a
long time so one advice I would give is
you know this be prepared for the long
haul you know it takes many many years
to make mark as a result is extremely
important to pick problems that you like
pick areas that you like so that you
have fun otherwise it's hard to actually
sustain the energy to run the marathon
the other advice I would give is to not
be lonely not do it alone
build a community of colleagues to
collaborate with you pick people that
have quite different skills from you to
collaborate so you can actually learn
from others you teach what you know you
actually learned from others this
research is very much a social process
that's another thing that I would
encourage and the other thing I would
encourage is now think about problems
that many many people care about real
world problems that if you actually
solve them it will make a real
difference and work on those problems
that are hard to solve you know rather
than you know count the number of papers
you publish all right I would say I
think it's it's far more satisfying to
do a few things that change the way
science progresses change the way of
field changes you know rather than have
a laundry list of publications
Shriram Rajamani I thank you for coming
all the way from Bangalore just to see
me
Cristiano I'm so happy that you spent
the time thinking about what a lab is
and doing this podcast and also thank
you for the opportunity to share this
story
Victor audience the gratitude is mutual
to learn more about dr. Sriram Rajamani
and the latest innovations out of ms
ours lab in India visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides